Ever wonder what’s under SCP-049’s
Venetian plague doctor mask?
Perhaps we should start calling
049 The Shy Guy instead of 096,
cause we’ve never seen this
guy’s face uncovered...hahaha.
Maybe he’s just a furry and
his fursona is a goth bird.
Maybe he’s got a terrible case of acne under
there that he’s really self-conscious about?..ha.
Maybe he’s hoping to be invited to an Eyes Wide
Shut-style masked swingers party sometime soon,
and he’s dressing for the job he
wants rather than the one he has.
Maybe, underneath that mask, he’s Dr. Oz,
who’s been using his daytime TV show to help
rid the world of The Pestilence for years.
Maybe, like the original Plague Doctors,
he wears it so that he doesn’t spread
or receive contaminants in the air.
Uhmmm...Or maybe he just wears it
because under that mask, he’s butt ugly?
Oh, what was that?
I see...Turns out, SCP-049’s mask is made out
of bone and attached to his head. It is his face.
Yikes! HAHA Sorry, buddy! HAHAHA….AAHHHHHH!!